right in new york new york city schools
will shut down tomorrow after
coronavirus test
positivity rates hit the three percent
threshold but
well new york governor andrew cuomo
apparently missed the memo because
he was suggesting schools would stay
open had an absolute meltdown on
reporters when pressed to answer key
questions about the future
of in-person learning take a look
and for the millions of parents who want
to know are the schools going to open
tomorrow in new york city
all right first of all let's try not to
be obnoxious
and offensive in your tone
because you're 100 wrong
we announced the orange zone law
over a month ago i don't know if you
were here
or if you were paying attention how what
are you talking about
you're now going to override we did it
already
that's the law an orange zone in a red
zone
follow the facts still confused well
then you're confused
i think he's correct in asking that
question i don't think it's obnoxious at
all
well i don't really care what you think
right after that they announced it
anyway now we're learning more tonight
about
california governor gavin newsom's fancy
dinner party where he was caught
breaking his own draconian coven 19
restrictions
look at this new photos obtained by fox
11's bill malugen
showing newsome seated with a large
group it looked pretty close together
not a lot of social distancing
at california's famous french laundry
restaurant
never heard of it no mass no social
distancing
elbow to elbow and it gets worse because
at the same dinner
where california medical association
officials
you can't make this up which exposes all
the rampant hypocrisy even
even more but they want you to think
about no thanksgiving
over in pennsylvania far left governor
tom wolf now ordering ridiculous new
rules or caught
requiring masks in your home when people
from other households are gathering
california senator dianne feinstein
she was seen on capitol hill oh my gosh
without her mask
ask yourself why is it that the decision
makers those who
are supposed to be the experts are well
fined defying their own rules for
us only totally okay imposing draconian
lockdowns
breaking their own coveted restrictions
and it's way past time that
they're held accountable but also
tonight more good news in the race for
that vaccine
fisa now says its vaccine candidate
shows a 95 percent efficacy rate
and plans to formally request emergency
authorization within days
thankfully